[Music]
introduce James Dyson Sir James Dyson
knight of the realm and consummate
inventor who came out with the first
bagless cyclonic vacuum cleaner about 20
years ago and has since disrupted all
sorts of other consumer electronics
categories with the fan and the air
blade which sounds like a 747 taking off
all amazing products so I thought we
would just get started because the
product cycles seem to be shortening and
everyone expects you to come to market
with something very quickly these days
and yet you spent two decades possibly
in your garage tinkering before you came
up with your final prototype we tell us
a little bit about that well it wasn't
to decays but it was five years oh and I
built about five thousand one hundred
and twenty prototypes I would say you
know I'm a huge failure because I did
5,000 126 mistakes but no it took a long
time and things do I mean we're
developing battery technology that won't
be out for 15 years no electric motors
digital very high speed electric motors
they took ten years before we got them
to the market but you know when it gets
there instead of being like that and
clunky it's tiny
it goes 110,000 rpms against the 30,000
rpm it's twice as powerful and lasts
almost forever so it you know it's a
much much better product but it takes
time and you had a big development teams
doing it so that there's nothing wrong
with things taking time oh great
amen so but when you did come out with
this vacuum it was an incredibly
disruptive technology I mean you know
made a few elements yeah I would imagine
the Hoover's of the world were not too
pleased so what kind of resistance did
you meet when you came out with it well
the retailers didn't understand it at
first but when they did they were very
supportive the competition ignored it
hoping would go away
gradually one by one they started
copying it and you know we have the
usual thing of having to sue them but
I'm not
unfortunately because you I mean in
America you spend I think it's four
times as much on lawsuits as he do on
research and development so it's not a
good situation it's a pity because in
Americans love technology so you know
researching and developing technology is
much more interesting the fighting
lawsuits but there it is but you were
really trying to solve a problem a
common everyday problem which is that
vacuums sucked up dirt and air and dust
with bags and you removed that problem
do you see all design is a matter of
everyday problem-solving well for me it
is I mean I'm just an ordinary person I
was designed only they meant and trained
as an engineer and you know I could
angry about things that don't work in
hand drives
I've gone into laboratories and wash my
hands then I've gone on this endless
paper towels but I think of a huge waste
of paper towels and those hotter hand
dryers you stand there for ages and then
give up so we got angry about that and
we were messing around in the in the
labs with another product that used a
high-speed blade of air and we thought
wouldn't this be the way you know to
scrape water off your hands with a blade
of air rather than using all that heat
to try and evaporate the water and by
the way to chap your hands in the
process so we came up with the
technology it's made possible by again a
high-speed digital motor there which
again goes at 110,000 LPM and develops
incredible pressure so we get pressure
to come out of this 0.3 of a millimeter
slot here and it creates it's literally
like a windshield wiper it scrapes the
water off your hands it's quite a nice
feeling it see the skin and rippling a
bit yeah we yeah the work of that thing
is incredible I mean it's it really is
feels like a race car well it saves a
huge amount of energy you see it's 1/6
of the energy of a hot-air Hendra it's
it's 12 seconds not 40 seconds and it's
three times as environmentally friendly
as hand towels so and we do it's not the
reason we did it we did it because we
wanted to dry hands quickly but as it
turns out it saves a lot of energy and a
lot of carbon footprint so then you
didn't start out wanting to design a
green product it just ended up being a
byproduct of the good engineering now we
never do that I hate green wash and the
thing is I employ young engineers always
try and get graduates and graduates are
very idealistic and they've been taught
lean engineering at college and I love
lean engineering so what we do is lean
engineering so our latest vacuum
cleaners use far less plastic and a far
lighter than the early ones which
doesn't make them any flimsier because
we do really really extensive testing
trying to break them but it means that
lighter and use less energy to make them
and less plastic and of course they're
cheaper to make so we can because of
that we can put in more technology which
we otherwise wouldn't have been able to
do but you know what engineers do
they're not marketing people with green
wash the engineers doing lean
engineering which they find exciting
mmm-hmm
so let's talk about your engineering
team then because now you are of course
an international company and very well
established you have how many people
working for you
nearly four thousand four thousand
people so how do you continue that
spirit of innovation disruption when you
have 4,000 employees well I try to
always employ graduates because they
have no fear they have no experience I
don't want to experience I want people
who haven't done something before and
want to find a new and better way of
doing it and who have no fear of failure
because failure is so important only
it's what you learn from it if you if
you always succeed and always give the
right answer you're learning nothing
right so I want people who feel as
though they're pioneering and want to do
something in a different and better way
and the funny thing is that these
graduates and when they become managers
and they want to employ someone they
always I want someone with the
experience and it's laziness it's
because they think that the person
coming in won't need to be trained we
need to be helped which is of course
quite the reverse because you've got to
knock their
in order to get them back to be thinking
originally and graduates are good
straight away you don't have to train
graduates they they're brilliant
straight away I remember when I first
started and I was making not right
vacuum cleaner nice the world by
canisters vacuum cleaners so I had to
develop a canister vacuum cleaner but my
few engineers all five of them were busy
on the existing products I so I just had
a graduate straight from the Royal
College of Art where I came from and I
said get on with it we're going to do
you and I are going to do a Salina
canister vacuum cleaner together it's
the one sitting in MoMA by the way that
one so that was a graduate did that so
so how early graduate and then graduate
there these are they've gone through
graduate school or they're just like
fresh out of college fresh out of
college out of college yeah and you
don't have to train them the worst thing
to do is to train them just get them
doing something and it's brilliant what
they do I mean I don't have the ideas
any longer they all have the ideas
because they have no fear and new
experience and and they're really
enthusiastic and they want to change the
world so you really encourage them to
just feel their way into success yes yes
and I want to see their failures because
that's what you learn from I would say
if you if you if you got a golf club and
you sort of look at it you learn nothing
if you break it over your knee you learn
the strength of the golf club and what
is yield point is so failure is terribly
important turn reporting in schools as
well I mean the problem with schools is
there any teacher to give the right
answer
and you're bright if you give the right
answer quickly they don't teach you to
learn by experience or unknown by
failure and have no fear of failure
there's very few jobs in life where you
know the answer before you do it you
have to work it out author whatever you
have to work it out so why don't we
teach people at school to have failure
and learn by experience and you have a
foundation which is trying to encourage
young people to get into engineering I
know that there's a dearth of engineers
coming into the market in the hair
they're certainly as you know
States and you know meanwhile 40% of the
graduates in Singapore are engineering
graduates yeah 30 percent in China yeah
no we haven't got it here yes I mean the
the problem with the global marketplace
is that everything everyone can make
something a lot of people to make them
cheaper than weekend so to be successful
we've got to develop something they
haven't got that the world wants and
which you can patent so the Chinese
can't copy it so it's our in Diva Search
and Development in employing engineers
is much more than scientist is much more
important now there ever was in the past
and the shortage is going to be
astronomic I mean we have German
companies like Siemens coming to poach
our engineers over to England to pay to
our engineers the shortage in Europe and
the United States is is really serious
problem we can't go on as we did in the
past producing me two products but it's
like everybody else we've got to produce
products that have far better technology
and which everybody wants to buy so and
the problem is that you know 30 percent
of girls at school want to be models and
I was quite encouraged by the figure of
13 percent of girls want to become
scientists till I learnt that they all
wanted to be pathologists because of the
CSI proof so the thing is we're not in
schools we're not getting children to
see the excitement and fun in
engineering and in making things you
know the the line is that manufacturing
is repetitive and boring modern
manufacturing is not repetitive like
I'll show you it goes around all the
time
and it's certainly not boring it's very
exciting because you're having to
introduce automation and all sorts of
exciting things and and you're making
things all day long and what would be
more creative than that so is there a
lot of tinkering and making happening
kind of out in the open air at Dyson HQ
oh yes I mean what we have 2,000
engineers and we don't have too many
products because we try to concentrate
on projects but you know we're not going
to produce a product like anybody else's
or one which only has a marginal
improvement we want a big improvement if
you have a big improvement then we can
go and sell it in Japan
which manages our second-largest market
and over here because you love
technology here and we can charge a lot
for it and then make a lot of money and
that's important there's a point in
doing a business and there's not going
to make a lot of money so let's talk
about some of the other toys on the
stage here because really with every
product release you disrupt another
industry and you know this is the fan
mmm which well I've had to film shriek
at and stop my grandchildren shopping
their fingers through the grill and a
fan this blade spinning around
high-speed I think I chopped off their
daughter had their fingers on top and
this is also impossible to clean and
also that the blades chop the air and
you get this sort of buffeting sound
slightly esoteric but it's actually true
if you have it playing on your foot and
ah so this is there we go
and it takes in a very small amount of
air here in the compressor and pumps it
out through a one millimeter annulus
around here
and that creates a negative pressure
over this aerofoil section which sucks
in air from behind and then it expands
slightly and therefore creates more
negative pressure so you've got a huge
suction here and then you get something
called viscous shearing here so you end
up multiplying this original airflow
about 20 times so you'll get something
for nothing just by having a few
interesting shapes I feel like I'm
talking to someone at Boeing or
something it's like as if you are ladies
airplane well it is a little bit like an
airplane yeah in a very modest way and
tell us about this is the heater this is
the heater yeah which uses the same
principle but has barium titanate
semiconductors in here which are not as
hot as a resistance wire you know that
when you fit turn fan heaters on you get
that smell of burning dust because the
resistance Y is quite high temperature
this is much lower temperature
and so you don't get a burning smell and
of course you can touch the heater so
you know it's it's got various fit
projects the air they take the hot air
very well so it heats a room up quicker
than a normal fan heater I'm going to
use a slightly less electricity and then
the well we talked a bit about the air
blow yes and now the new vacuums are
working on this ball technology yeah cuz
I mean I thought vacuum cleaners were
heavy and they're because they've got
four wheels they're difficult to steer
because you keep having to go backwards
and forwards and then sort of do that to
get around something so we just put the
motor and all the workings down in the
ball so it's got a very low center of
gravity and then you just twist it and
go around that's great it's just that
easy to use and as I said very very very
light so are you excited about some of
the new enable I don't know how to empty
it you take you take the bin off and
then just empty I do have one of these
and you use the hose Deuter to get into
small places I clearly need to upgrade
my Dyson because that you did that with
much more facility than I do it at home
so we've made some improvement yes
indeed so there are all these exciting
new technologies of course that are
enabling rapid prototyping like 3d
printers do you use any of that
technology at all oh well of course and
actually nothing beats going out and
making a working prototype of something
which isn't necessarily a complete
product it might be a part of something
so we don't really use rapid prototyping
for that but the may and the trouble is
that people tend to use rapid
prototyping and did a good sort of
immediate
example of what they've designed on the
screen and that's not very good but what
it's really useful for is doing lots and
lots of prototypes which you can go out
into real homes and test and put onto
user courses and put through mechanical
test systems so it's really useful for
that enormous it time-saving and if you
were to choose another consumer product
that really frustrates you now what
would it be
well looking at NU oh that would be a
giveaway but I mean almost everything is
frustrating when you think about it an
anger is a great motivator
indeed so tell us a little bit we you
just quickly broached the idea of China
moving in to the marketplace and that
you have several lawsuits knowing what
what has been your experience expanding
into that market well we don't sell
there at the moment we probably will but
we used to manufacture some things there
but we pulled it out it's a great market
and I think it I mean the trouble is
they don't buy vacuum cleaners because
they have a servant who sweeps the floor
and they tend to buy Burberry's and
Bentley's which they can show off so
it's not at the moment it's not a great
market but it will be it will be and we
are going in there but there's many
other actually more interesting
Southeast Asian markets are us like
Japan which is a wonderful market where
they love technology they're very
sophisticated and Taiwan and Singapore
and Malaysia these are great markets as
well behind there isn't the only market
there mm-hmm
but but you clearly are protecting your
patents and as much whole property is
important to you as a product designer
and we talked a little bit before about
open source design
you know there's a movement towards that
which is kind of counter to intellectual
property and and how do you feel about
this new movement of open source design
where people are collaborating on mass
on you know iterating new new
developments and product design and yet
you know you really do have to protect
your patent and your intellectual
property if you have something that is
is radically redesigning a product well
I think the patents encourage
competition if you didn't have patents
and you couldn't protect what you did no
one would develop anything there won't
be any point because if you can develop
something as someone copies it you're
not gonna you're gonna lose money
because they haven't had the development
costs or for that matter the patent
costs they just copy it and you know
they've had no costs so you've got to
have patents to create competition so if
I do something and patent it someone
else has to create something else to
compete with mine and they patent it and
we're in competition mm-hmm so some
people suggest that the patents restrict
competition I think it's exactly the
reverse so and then that's let's circle
back then again to how what the what
your foundation is doing to encourage
young designers and young engineers I
know you have a pilot program in Chicago
yeah we have we're doing after-school
clubs to teach them design in technology
so we give them vacuum cleaners to take
the bits and let them back together
again and then they can make their own
projects and I've seen them do this no
that is wonderful I mean in one are a
group of three children did a device to
mince up kitchen waste and blow it
outside into a bin because they hated
the smelly bin with a food rotting away
in it you know they got angry about a
problem and found a solution to it
he's an 11 year old kids it's great to
see that the after-school clubs there
was one boy who's absolutely hell-bent
on being a lawyer but now he wants to be
an engineer
you got a regatta we've got in any one
that it's a start that's great well you
know III really want to hear a little
bit more about how you what you're
prototyping process is like and how you
train your young engineers to not only
accept failure but to be real risk
takers I know that we spoke a little bit
about how when you started out it was
impossible to get any money from venture
capitalists because they were afraid of
product and so I mean the good thing is
is that now you call the shots on the
company but you know that that's a tough
process and and you know you have always
really encouraged risk-taking but it's
incredibly important yes when I when I
started I went to venture capitalist to
try and raise money and I said well the
vacuum cleaner looks quite interesting
but we're not investing in you because
you're an engineer anyway
that's mr. Honda and akio morita as
example people I mean reasonably
successful by being engineer's
but now I think I think the the of
course bringing out new products is a
risk it's a huge risk and it isn't just
the development costs it's the tooling
costs the plant and equipment costs the
launch costs normal amount of money but
it's exciting it's fun and if you don't
do it it's very dull and also if you
don't do it people catch up so it's
absolutely essential to do it I mean
there are businesses that make their
money by copying people and then there
are businesses that try to make a living
by creating things and you know I'm a
witch camper I'd like to be in and
engineers want to be you know
particularly young engineers want to be
inventive they really want to change
things and do things differently and
it's you know it's not very hard to get
them to do it I mean just allow them to
make mistakes and when they have an idea
you know sitting around and talking
about something they have an idea you
just say well gonna make it go and try
it
it won't work we're going try nice and
it will work eventually but it
don't be disappointed it doesn't work
the first time right find out what went
wrong and then work out ways to overcome
it so it's allowing people to make silly
mistakes to make silly suggestions
obtuse suggestions and not laugh at them
just said yeah that sounds interesting
going to it but the worst celeste
suggestions are the correct suggestions
of obvious suggestions they're just
irritating you've got what we want is
people to make you know very obtuse some
different ways of doing things
mm-hm so what other companies do you
admire who who else is taking risks
right now well I dunno I don't I'm so
busy doing what I'm doing I don't really
look around or what other people are
doing but you know I'm sure other people
doing wonderful things I'm keeping
myself rather busy doing clearly well
thank you so much for being here I think
we'll take some questions from the
audience and from our Twitter stream the
question here in front of me does
product make the brand or does brand
make the product
well there's any one word I banned in my
company and that's the word brand I
don't believe in it at all
you're only as good as the product
you're making people buy a product they
didn't buy a brand they nearby our
company and what interested in our
company they buy our product and we're
only as good as our latest product so I
don't believe in brand at all sorry
[Music]
mr. Dyson yeah who's Patrick Birmingham
you graduated at st. Martin's School of
Fine Art what did you learn at art
college that still informs or influences
the decisions you make today well that's
a very good question I went to a
wonderful College called the Royal
College of Art in London it's called the
Royal College well actually most of it
is design and I learnt about design and
you know design College you can you can
dream you can build a product you really
like and and have experts help you you
can go over to Imperial College and
famous Science College next door and get
help and it's a actually the best thing
it did was to tell me that it's no good
just being a designer it's like a
negative thing actually it's no good
just being a designer you've got to make
a product that works better so I went
off to an engineering company for seven
years to learn how to do research and
development but I never got there if it
hadn't been for this College telling me
about design and getting me to well a
dream and be ambitious but also teaching
me how to design things Barry Ritholtz
results Capital Management I love the
clever application of engineering and
the smart ways you apply physics but I'm
just curious about the day of James
Dyson do you walk through life seeing
all sorts of just terribly designed
products and machinery like is your life
just what is this piece of garbage that
you're constantly interacting with well
I'm delighted to meet a venture
capitalist interested in engineering and
science well I do now think all the
engineers do that you go around and you
know you want to know how something
works and if it isn't very satisfactory
it displeases you and it's actually it's
it's inspirational you know there's an
opportunity to do something better why
didn't they do this so engineers just do
that naturally I think like I presume
doctors do when they see someone ill you
know so and it's fun but it's yes it is
annoying sometimes
says here's something badly designed
there's an interesting thing about
design is design think everybody thinks
design is about how something looks so
you know when you think of design you
think of someone in a pink shirt with a
felt-tip pens then when something
doesn't work you kick it and you say who
designed this so and the latter form is
really what a designer is is someone who
not only makes things look good and
lasts a long time
they're high quality but also make new
uses new technology and even work better
we have a Twitter question how much of
your time is spent managing versus
investing ah ah did well now since I
don't invest but I just want to do new
products I often don't wonder about how
much they cost we just do them because
someone does tell me how much they cost
but I don't manage at all because I'm
the hopeless manager so other people
might do what's called managing and I go
and be with my engineers and just get
involved in designing developing new
product new technology new products so
I'm lucky enough to have got to the
point in the business where I didn't
have to manage anybody which is
wonderful I don't think I ever did
anyway actually I mean I just we just
got on with things one last question
[Music]
thank you Frank Gibney you you talk
about being in it and you are an
engineer a wonderful engineer but you
went to the Royal College of Art what
does the difference between artists and
engineers and yeah that's it well not a
lot
they're both you know trying to create
something different
yes it's Royal College of Art and Design
and I actually studied architecture but
not a lot I think the same subject I
could so I don't know is that you there
I like to face it ask me the question do
I think a designer or an artist is
probably more interested in how
something looks and the reaction you get
when you look at what you're looking at
whereas an engineer is much more
concerned probably with what goes on
inside and the technology being used and
how reliable it is and how long it lasts
and how much it costs so I think for me
I mean I I couldn't be an artist because
I I need all those other complex issues
to worry about
I couldn't just worry about how
something looks but I mean that's how
you made up I mean David Hockney was
brilliant and articulate and he paints
the most wonderfully invented paintings
but I just worked out what made me tick
and what would turn me on and it was
engineering for me and developing
technology well we're glad you went that
way thanks so much
[Applause]